bonjour les jeux profitent de ta série
de vidéos sur l'intelligence
artificielle pour te poser une question
tu le sais je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
biais cognitifs et aux défauts de
fonctionnement du cerveau humain qui
nous empêche de penser correctement
par exemple quand on obtient des données
brutes issues d'une étude scientifique
par exemple on les interprète souvent de
travers les statistiques on peut leur
faire dire ce qui nous arrange le plus
selon ce qu'on a envie d'entendre
pour éviter ces biais certains pensent
qu'une solution serait d'utiliser des
algorithmes c'est fiable c'est neutre
qu'en penses tu à ton avis est ce que un
algorithme peut avoir des billets tu
peux donner un exemple voici un exemple
issu du paranormal parce que c'est ce
que je connais bien
dans les années 50 il y avait une étude
qui montrait un lien entre les
performances sportives et la position en
quarts et de la planète mars dans le
thème astrologique de certains sportifs
on appelait ça l'effet mars et sans
parler du fait que il choisissait les
critères qu'il utilisait pour
sélectionner les sportifs qui allait
participer à son étude pour maximiser
ses résultats il y avait aussi un billet
d'interprétation a posteriori des
statistiques
il y avait effectivement moins de 5% une
chance qu'il obtienne ses résultats par
hasard avec mars en quart et avec des
résultats sportifs mais il avait aussi
essayé avec toutes les autres planètes
toutes les autres conjonction et avec
plein d'autres critères le score
handicapées en mathématiques en histoire
c'est là un bel exemple de pi hacking à
ton avis or il suffit de automatiser les
études statistiques avec des algorithmes
pour éviter de tels billets alors là
clairement non en fait le fait
d'utiliser des algorithmes est-ce que
forte aggraver les biens dans l'analyse
de données
et ça c'est parce qu'il ya un biais
fondamental dans toute analyse de
données qui n'est absolument pas
spécifique à l'humain ce biais c'est le
biais de la surinterprétation que l'on
appelle aussi over fitting dans le
langage du machine learning en gros la
surinterprétation c'est lorsque l'on
cherche trop à expliquer les données et
du coup ce faisant on risque de mettre
le contexte autour de la collecte de
données ainsi que les fluctuations
statistiques qui sont présentes dans
tout jeu de données or il est très
facile de concevoir des algorithmes qui
vont automatiquement détecté des
irrégularités dans des jeux de données
sans tenir compte ni du contexte ni des
fluctuations statistiques dans les
données utilisées étaient algorithmes
c'est aussi et surtout facilité
la découverte de corrélation
fallacieuses ah oui il y à même ce
fameux site qui s'appelle spurs
corrélation qui propose de fouiller dans
une immense base de données pour y
dénicher toutes sortes de corrélation
entre des variables qui n'ont aucune
raison d'être corrélés on y découvre par
exemple que le nombre de films avec
nicolas cage est corrélée avec le nombre
de personnes noyées en tombant dans une
piscine l'importation de pétrole brut
aux états unis venant de norvège est
corrélée avec le nombre de conducteurs
morts par collisions avec des trains ou
encore que l'âge de miss américain est
corrélée avec le nombre de meurtres par
vapeur chaude même corrélation n'est pas
causalité et oui surtout dans ce cas
parce que là on est typiquement dans un
cas de sur interprétations
quand on regarde ces graves de
corrélation il faut absolument se dire
qu'il s'agit d'une poignée de graff
intrigant parmi un énorme ensemble de
graff étudié par l'algorithme en fait
spurs collation à étudier des
corrélations entre des milliers de jeux
de données ce qui lui a fait des
millions d'études de corrélation chaque
corrélation est peu probable mais même
si les jeux de données était
complètement aléatoire la probabilité
d'une corrélation significative entre
deux jeux de données restent non nul
or si cette probabilité elle ne serait
ce que de l'ordre de 1% ce qui n'est
vraiment pas beaucoup alors une
corrélation sur 100 sera significative
sur les millions de corrélation étudiée
il resterait des dizaines de milliers de
corrélation significative et spears
corrélation a justement publié 30000
corrélation significative
j'ai l'impression que votre cerveau a
tendance à imaginer que si un phénomène
a très peu de chances de se produire
alors ce genre de phénomène devrait se
produire très rarement ce qui est une
erreur un individu spécifique a très peu
de chances de gagner au loto
si je gagne au loto cette semaine c'est
extraordinaire mais vu qu'il ya
énormément de joueurs
le fait que l'un d'entre eux gagne au
loto ça c'est ordinaire
il ya des gagnants toutes les semaines
de la même façon on surinterprète ce
genre de corrélation on y voit un lien
de cause à effet alors que c'est juste
du à la taille gigantesque de la base de
données le biais de surinterprétation
c'est omettre la probabilité que le
hasard puisse générer des régularités ou
des patterns
sauf qu'en fait bien souvent il est très
improbable que le hasard ne produisent
pas au moins une régularité
si vous regardez le hasard avec soin
vous finirez pas retrouvé de telle
régularité et comme les algorithmes sont
capables de regarder les données avec
bien plus de soins que nous ils seront
capables de trouver bien plus de
régularité créneau mais en fait l'erreur
n'est pas temps d'observer ces
régularités l'erreur du biais de sur
interprétations c'est surtout de penser
que ces régularités doivent s'expliquer
autrement que par le hasard
ok même il ya un autre problème avec les
études sur le paranormal
c'est le biais de confirmation non
seulement on cherche des phénomènes
surprenants de façon générale mais
surtout on cherche on particulier mais
phénomène sur lesquels on a envie de
croire
est-ce que les algorithmes seraient
exempts du biais de confirmation
l'encore j'ai envie de dire non si on
utilise des algorithmes et notamment si
on utilise de mauvaises algorithmes
alors on risque au contraire d'amplifier
le risque de biais de confirmation et il
ya un excellent exemple de cela sur le
site people y ait de night fever et ses
collaborateurs
ce site vous demande d'imaginer que vous
êtes un terme au crac hooligans vous
voulez montrer à tout prix que si les
démocrates sont au pouvoir alors
l'économie va mieux
manque de bol le pib ne semble pas
corrélée avec le fait que le président
au pouvoir soit démocrate
c'est embêtant mais armé de votre
puissant biais de confirmation vous vous
dites que ce qui compte ce n'est pas
tant le pib et oui le chômage c'est
important aussi
hélas la corrélation augmente yes mais
elle n'est pas encore suffisamment
grande pour être publiables et
convaincre ces idiots du camp opposé qui
croient encore qu'on peut sauver
l'économie en étant républicain et c'est
là que vous vous dites que le président
peut avoir les mains liées a minima il
faudrait aussi considérer le cas où les
gouverneurs sont majoritairement
démocrate
du coup pour fait l'analyse de données
et là bingo
cette fois votre coloration est clair
net et scientifiquement publiable elle a
une paix va lieu inférieure à 1% ce qui
est mieux que le standard usuelle des
sciences vous venez de démontrer que les
démocrates ont un effet bénéfique sur
l'économie
d'ailleurs pour plus de détails sur la
paix value je vous recommande cet
excellent épisode de la statistique
expliqué à mon chat alors bien sûr
démontré dans ce cas c'est un bien grand
mot mais si vous écrivez un article qui
omet la démarche intellectuelle que vous
a conduit à votre corrélation et qui se
contentent uniquement de publier le
résultat significatif ce qui on va pas
se le cacher et souvent le cas des
publications scientifiques
alors votre article sera parfaitement
aux standards de la méthode scientifique
- f mais on sent bien qu'il ya quelque
chose qui cloche dans ce résultat
significatif est en effet imaginons
maintenant que je sois al'inverse un
républicain hooligans alors je pourra
rétorquer qu'en fait le chômage est la
vraie plaie de nos sociétés et que c'est
ça qu'il faudrait supprimer pour
améliorer l'économie
du coup je refais l'analyse de données
sans prendre en compte le pib est là de
façon étonnante
j'obtiens un résultat tout aussi
significatif qui dit exactement l'opposé
de la corrélation précédente avec une
paie value inférieure à 1%
je conclus que les démocrates sont
néfastes à l'économie n'est exactement
là dans une situation de sur
interprétations
quelle que soit la fluence réel des
politiques sur l'économie on peut
bidouiller l'analyse de données pour
conclure une chose et son contraire
pire encore on y est arrivé à la main
imaginez maintenant que des armes et de
militants hooligans lancent chacun de
son côté des algorithmes pour collecter
et étudier des corrélations
significatives qui supportent leur camp
alors chaque camp pourra facilement
publié des milliers de corrélation
significative qui semble prouver que
leur camp elle le bon camp en fait le
problème dans ce cas c'est qu'une phrase
comme les démocrates ont un effet
bénéfique sur l'économie est en fait
très ambigu on peut l'interpréter de
plein de manières différentes
est ce qu'on parle d'un président
démocrate de gouverneur démocrate d'un
sénat démocrate ou d'une combinaison de
président et de gouverneurs et comment
mesurer l'économie parce que le pays des
contes cruels chômage ou l'inflation ou
la bourse ou une combinaison de tout ça
et quelle combinaison vous voyez que ça
fait plein de questions qui sont en fait
différentes les unes des autres
sauf que n'importe laquelle des très
nombreuses reformulation de cette
question nous semblera a posteriori
conforme avec la phrase les démocrates
ont en effet bénéfique sur l'économie
est typiquement si on collecte 3
corrélations significatives obtenues via
ce genre de questions ça semblera
justifier un titre put à cliquer de ce
genre dans votre journal votre émission
de télé préférées le noeud du problème
c'est que le nombre de reformulation
compatible avec une phrase de ce genre
est énorme du coup même s'il est
improbable pour chaque reformulation
d'être une corrélation significative
il est alors bien plus improbable qu
qu'une reformulation n'y parvienne pire
encore on peut juste complexifier les
reformulations à l'infini jusqu'à
aboutir à une conclusion qui va dans
notre sens
or ça ça ce code très très facilement
avec des algorithmes ses algorithmes
seront alors bien plus performant que
nous pour rationaliser nos intuitions
ils seront donc bien plus victimes du
biais de confirmation et bien sûr tout
ce que je dis là n'est pas du tout
spécifique à la politique
on retrouve exactement le même problème
dans plein de sujets de société
par exemple quand on dit que le café est
bon pour la santé que le paris saint
germain a mérité de gagner
ou encore que les ja sont dangereuses
pour nos sociétés je ne dis pas que ces
princes sont vraies ou fausses
ce que je dis c'est qu'il sera très
facile pour un algorithme de bidouiller
toutes sortes de données pour conclure
exactement cela ou son contraire
tout ça parce qu'il existe un énorme
nombre de reformulation rigoureuse qui a
posteriori sonneront parfaitement
conforme
avec ses phrases ok je comprends mais là
tu parles d'algorithmes militants est-ce
qu'on aurait encore ce genre de problème
de biais de confirmation avec des
algorithmes nos militants tout dépend de
l'algorithme et en particulier de ceux
que le concepteur de l'algorithme veut
que l'algorithme face aujourd'hui dans
le monde académique comme dans la presse
il faut publier des résultats étonnants
et intrigant pour survivre publish or
perish comme disent certains
du coup jean sent-il des chercheurs et
des médias c'est de concevoir des
algorithmes qui iront pouilles et des
jeux de données pour y trouver des
corrélations étonnante sur des sujets
polarisant donc civiquement si je devais
publier un truc qui fasse le buzz
je ne cherchera pas nécessairement une
corrélation significative qui montre que
les démocrates ont un effet bénéfique
sur société mais je chercherai une
corrélation significative qui dit
quelque chose sur l'impact d'un parti
politique sur l'économie et dès que
j'aurai trouvé une telle corrélation je
les publierai et les militants du parti
que ça arrange pour ont massivement la
partager ainsi même sans un algorithme
partisan je favoriserai le hooliganisme
politique
ben merci les c'est fascinant et puis ça
regonfle bien sûr les études sur
l'astrologie et l'effet mars
il suffit qu'il y ait une étude qui
aille dans ce sens et qui soit
significative pour qu'elles soient
facilement aux publié est largement
partagée à travers les médias du coup
même si les astres n'avait aucun effet
sur nos destinées les lois du hasard
font qu'il serait très improbable qu'il
n'y ait aucun résultat scientifique qui
aille dans ce sens et qu'ils soient
publiés de façon plus générale il est
indispensable de se demander comment les
données ont été collectées pour pouvoir
payer les analyser ces données sont
plaints d'imprécisions dans leurs
mesures
pire encore elles ont souvent été
sélectionnées parmi un ensemble bien
plus grand de données surtout quand il
s'agit de données publiée dans une revue
scientifique ou dans un article de
presse
tout humain ou algorithmique qui
analysent ces données en supposant qu'il
s'agit de données brutes sans
fluctuations statistiques ni biais de
sélection sera alors en grave danger de
sur interprétations
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
un énorme merci à christophe michel de
la chaîne hygiène mentale aller voir sa
chaîne c'est absolument génial ce qui
fait c'est un petit peu le maître à
penser de la zététique française et ses
vidéos sont vraiment d'une qualité
absolument génial se fait vraiment
partie de ce qu'il ya de mieux sur
youtube
pour le coup ce sont vraiment des vidéos
d'intérêt public absolument énorme je
recommande notamment vivement ces vidéos
sur les arguments fallacieux qui est
mort un excellent depuis la série de
vidéos qu'il a fait
en filmant ce qui se passe dans une
école où ils apprennent l'esprit
critique ce je pense que ce genre de
séance est absolument génial et faut
vraiment que ça se développe en plus si
dernière fois on a vu comment on pouvait
toujours bidouiller un enjeu de données
pour pouvoir finalement appliqué des
méthodes de régression ou de
classification linéaire la bidouille non
linéaire c'est typiquement un exemple de
cas on risque fort le biais de la
surinterprétation et hervé le borgne
fait leur marque qu on dit parfois
plutôt sur un apprentissage que sur
interprétation par exemple la page
wikipedia s'appelle sur apprentissage et
pas sur interprétations je trouve que
cette terminologie est horriblement mal
choisi pour le coup je déteste cette
terminologie est hors de question
qu'elle utilise pas ce que sur
l'apprentissage conduit facilement un
contresens dans l'impression que le sur
apprentissage c'est le fait d'avoir trop
appris et du coup quand on apprend entre
hauts et bas ont fini par comprendre le
monde du coup d'aller à l'école alors
que la surinterprétation ça correspond
avant tout un mauvais apprentissage qui
est dû au fait que on a donné trop
d'importance aux données est d'ailleurs
un des outils indispensables pour éviter
ce problème de la surinterprétation
consiste justement à apprendre plus de
théorie et à s'enfermer un petit peu
plus dans la théorie et a accepté en
particulier les erreurs que la théorie
pourrait faire sur certains jeux de
données
c'est typiquement la proche qui avait
suivi galilée au xviie siècle quand il a
découvert notamment la loi de la chute
des corps ou le principe de relativité
comme on en avait parlé dans les
épisodes 200 vols de la série sur la
relativité
j'insiste encore un peu sur ça parce que
j'ai besoin souvent dans la
vulgarisation scientifique on va dire
que l'empirisme c'est super important il
faut absolument coller aux données alors
que il ya quand même tout un aspect
ultra important dans l'apprentissage qui
est l'apprentissage des théories quitte
à ce que ces théories ne colle pas
parfaitement aux données et d'ailleurs
cette tension entre la théorie et
l'empirisme c'est quelque chose dont on
reparlera dans la prochaine vidéo
mathieu aurousseau demande si le nom de
loi gaussienne vient pas du fait que cos
a calculé le à de l'expression a foi en
puissance - bx carrés où il faut choisir
le raté que ce fut une intégrale c'est à
dire si je calcule la probabilité total
d'une valeur de x dont m il faut que ce
soit une probabilité de tout l'espace du
groupe dassault égal à 1 du coup faut
ajuster leur art en fonction du coût
calcul ra revient à essayer de
déterminer la valeur de l'intégrale de
puissance 3 x car et je sais pas si
martin on reçoit fait exprès de poser
cette question des russes poirier
l'organisme l'a placée en moi
mais nous aux [ __ ] c'est la place qui
a trouvé cette valeur de excusez-moi 16
120 ne fait remarquer que même en maths
en fait il ya pas mal de bidouiller des
trucs pas beau et alors ces gosses qui
disait que ben une fois qu'on a prouvé
un théorème on va mettre l'épreuve un
petit peu de côté et on voit pas
forcément les montrer parce que c'est un
petit peu moche on va juste montrer
l'élégance du théorème faisait une par
une comparaison avec les visent en
disant que les échafauds de l'église à
la fin ils sont enlevés pour qui juste
l'église notamment sur edit il ya eu un
commentaire que je trouve assez amusant
de phoques terre seven qui part d'un
professeur en théorie des nombres
analytique qui au moment de commencer
des preuves assez dégueu disait alors la
preuve que l'on va faire et si on classe
et est une c'est un truc qui l'ont fait
dans la sphère privée de vos propres
chambres
bref il ya des trucs absolument élégant
merveilleux en mathématiques via aussi
il faut le reconnaître des trucs assez
dégueu silva refusé à adrien bruno me
pose des questions sur la vidéo est
utilisée par alpha 0 et alpha 0 c'est un
exemple que je trouve fascinant parce
que c'est un problème en fait résoudre
le jeu d'échecs le jeu de go tous ces
jeux de société de façon générale c'est
des jeux informations complètes dont on
est fascinant capable d'écrire des
algorithmes et des algorithmes même très
courts qui sont capables de résoudre
c'est je le prenne de ces accords et
emma c'est uniquement une question de
temps de calcul qui ça fait vraiment
référence à l'épisode 6 qu'on a bu ou
david celli a parlé de structures pour
le jeu de la vie qui est pourtant un
truc totalement déterministe dont on
connaît les règles et les conditions ont
finalement c'est qu'à ce que l'on
cherche à faire c'est d'approcher un
algorithme conseillers déjà optimale
mais dont le temps de gars que ya
absolument énorme et du coup on cherche
à approcher les calculs de cet
algorithme optimale avec un algorithme
qui est rapide en temps de calcul mais
du coup qui va sacrifier un peu on aura
qualité de l'approximation et du couffo
ajusté pour que c'est la vaccination
soit suffisamment bonne
tout en ayant tu vois une approximation
qui soit facile à calculer en temps réel
via ce moment est ce que fait alpha 0
c'est absolument génial ça correspond
vraiment à l'intuition concours espèrent
quand on observe le jeu de la vie c'est
de se dire bon bah au lieu de regarder
tous les détails des calculs qu on doit
faire on va essayer d'avoir une vision
intuitive approximative une fonction
approximative qui essaie de dire qu'est
ce qui se passe
notamment cette fonctionnel dans le cas
de alpha 0 ou d'alpha go c'est une
fonction en fait qui est un réseau de
neurones qui apprend de données qu'on
lui donne un peu comme dans le jeu la
vie on voit des données mais c'est
d'inférer des règles approximative du à
partir des données exactes qui ont été
calculés on cherche des règles
approximative et rien que ça c'est un
problème c'est pas résoudre autrement
que via diverses artificielle et le
machine learning
aujourd'hui un autre truc que je tiens à
dire sur alpha 0 qui a un truc assez
ahurissant quand vous y réfléchissez
c'est que alpha 0 c'est un truc qui est
techniquement voilà c'est un algorithme
qu'on aura peut-être pu avoir conçu il
ya dix vingt ans parce qu'au final pour
sa puissance de calcul et quand même est
assez énorme peut-être pas 20 ans mais
finalement elle a réussi à faire tous
ces calculs en 24 heures il a réussi à
apprendre à jouer aux échecs mieux que
n'importe quel autre cargo étaient des
échecs en seulement quatre heures donc
ça laisse penser que termes
d'apprentissage algorithmique interne
d'algorithmes d'apprentissage en terme
de leurs dix machines zurich mais on est
encore très très mauvais on est très
très loin des algorithmes
d'apprentissage aussi bon que le cerveau
des vivants ou loin de trucs optimaux
en un certain sens et parfois j'entends
dire que ça ça montre que l'intelligence
artificielle on en est très très loin
en effet ça veut dire n'est pas du tout
mais ça veut aussi et surtout dire qu'il
ya énormément de progrès qui sont pas
forcément si difficile à faire dans la
conception d'intelligence artificielle
ans directeur de tasiast mets
typiquement raconté que quand un
industriel venait le voir lui disais
voilà qu'est ce que vous êtes capable de
faire en optimisation par rapport à
notre système est aujourd'hui mon
directeur de thèse répondait bas ça
dépend à quel point vous êtes mauvais je
suis pas sûr que le disait exactement
comme ça mais c'était un peu ça l'idée
si on est mauvais en quelque chose qu'on
peut beaucoup progresser alors que si on
est déjà très très très bon proche des
limites de la physique de ce qui peut se
faire là et progrès sont beaucoup plus
difficiles et en termes d'intelligence
artificielle notamment d'algorithmes
d'apprentissage exemple d'alpha 0 montre
justement à quel point on est encore
mauvais on tu en es tu es mauvais avant
alpha 0 et je pense qu'il ya énormément
de progrès à faire en intelligence
artificielle en machine learning dans le
développement de ces notamment aux
algorithmes d'apprentissage et ça ça
laisse vraiment à penser qu'il y aura
encore énormément de progrès dans les
années à venir une intelligence
artificielle et sans doute que le
progrès va être encore assez
spectaculaire enfin je vais finir avec
sébastien pas le coup qui recommande une
vidéo notamment de à l'inconnu ou qui
donnent un séminaire et à la fin de son
séminaire haricots ne tape un petit peu
sur la machine learning et
l'intelligence artificielle en disant
notamment que ces machine learning
n'arrive pas à porter le même niveau de
compréhension des choses que ceux dont
les humains sont capables
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez vrai
pas toutes en grève mais c'est à ses
bras souvent les algorithmes
apprentissage qui utilisés notamment
pour résoudre des problèmes en
mathématiques c'est des trucs qui vont
faire des grosses exploration cette idée
des grosses bidouille et l'épreuve qui
en ressortent
damman pas dans le cas du théorème du
carreleur que j'avais présenté sur
science au final ce sont pas forcément
des preuves qui sont aussi intéressantes
pour des mathématiciens
ceci étant dit c'est aussi parce que les
algorithmes d'aujourd'hui l'intérieur
sera signé aujourd'hui est très loin du
niveau humain et surtout il 13 incapable
se mettre à un autre niveau des nous
expliquer la manière dont il faut penser
à différents problèmes gros les
intelligences artificielles aujourd'hui
donc aucune compréhension de la
pédagogique est nécessaire pour
comprendre et du vin cependant je pense
que à long terme plus marquants du tout
mais je pense qu'à long terme les
intelligences artificielles comprendront
mieux la pédagogie pour les humains que
les humains prennent eux mêmes
à ce moment là en fait c'est intelligent
certes i7 devra être capable bien mieux
que nous de nous expliquer les choses
intéressantes à comprendre en
mathématiques
et si jamais elle n'y arrive pas j'ai
envie de dire que finalement
l'intelligence artificielle c'est comme
un mathématicien un mathématicien
aujourd'hui si on prend pendant que la
conjecture a b c ou d une conjecture à
laquelle il ya une preuve depuis 2012
quelque chose comme ça proposé par
mochizuki un mathématicien japonais la
preuve fait 500 pages est bon je crois
qu'aujourd'hui a peut-être deux ou trois
personnes qui ont lu la preuve en quoi
est-ce que mouche isu qui est vraiment
différente d'une intelligence
artificielle qui aurait écrit une preuve
de 500 pages j'ai envie de dire que dans
les deux cas malheureusement pas ce
qu'ils ont fait est tellement compliqué
que nous autres pauvres humains qui ne
sommes pas pu choquer ou l'intelligence
artificielle prend pas ce qu'ils ont
fait forcément elle espère qu'ils
avaient une et cet épisode que vous
allez faire attention apport à la
surinterprétation d'ailleurs le prochain
épisode de parlera encore du problème de
la surinterprétation multi de laxou
d'interprétation aux particules
devraient se poser la question
imaginez une pièce dont huit fois de
suite surface est-ce qu'elle va encore
tomber surface au prochain en selle
après l'autre vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le lit qu'elle augmente à le
partager pensez vous
la prochaine fois demandé leur avis aux
gens qui sont le plus impliquées
je pense que c'est la pire des méthodes
ceux qui sont au coeur de l'activité
sans justement les personnes qui ont la
vision la plus biaisée par exemple un
journaliste qui voudraient savoir s'il
ya beaucoup de criminalité dans sa ville
il y aura probablement tendre un micro
aux policiers qui prend la déposition à
l'accueil du commissariat
à votre avis qu'est-ce qui va répondre
bah oui c'est clair vous imaginez pas
tout ce qu'on voit ici tient pas plus
tard que hier ben ya un type qui bla bla
bla ce type là toute la journée
il ne voit que des gens qui ont
justement des problèmes il a le nez
dedans
ce qu'il faut c'est au contraire avoir
du recul il faut comparer les
statistiques de la criminalité avec la
moyenne nationale en gardant bien à
l'esprit tous les biais de déclarations
qui peuvent venir fausser les
comparaisons
c'est un travail de sociologie et donc
notre journaliste ferait mieux d'aller à
l'université pour interviewer des
chercheurs qui travaillent sur la
criminalité